how many leaders talked about when they
were really struggling during covet
um I went you know at the beginning of
covid I called a friend of mine we had
to Pivot our organization we had because
what we made most of our money from
in-person events and I called a friend
of mine whose active duty military
and I said how do you compartmentalize
your emotions so you can stay Mission
focused because I gotta stay Mission
focused I don't have time to worry about
what's going on
and he gave me a very Stern warning he
said you can't he said no one can
compartmentalize their emotions he says
at best we can do it for a short period
of time but every single one of us will
suffer the trauma of combat because the
hard part is you may not suffer it in
the moment you may suffer it four or
five or six months later after you've
been home already
he says so the stern warning is you're
going to suffer the trauma of covet at
some point
and I called all my a-type personality
friends and said we're going to be hit
there's no avoiding it no matter how you
know strong we think we are it's going
to hit us and we all made a deal to call
each other if we started to struggle and
sure enough one by one four five six
months into covid the phone started to
ring and people were really struggling
and we all made a deal that there's we
never cry alone if you have to cry you
call somebody that was the deal we made
with each other
and um sure enough almost on schedule
about four or five months in I started
to go through my depression
didn't was did struggle to recognize it
right was afraid to call it depression
because you know I'm a happy-go-lucky
guy I don't have depression I don't want
to be a diagnosed right but that's what
it was I was suffering Trauma from covet
and
um one of the first things I did was uh
talk to my team
uh well actually the first thing I did
was I called active military friend and
said what are your symptoms when you
suffered the trauma of
and he said he answered my question he
said well
um I my my sleep pattern gets really
screwed up he said I go to bed really
late for no reason and I don't want to
get out of bed in the morning and I was
like yep and he's like I I don't really
want to talk to anybody I become really
anti-social and I'm definitely not
asking anybody for help and I was like
yep and he's like and um I'm
unproductive he says I'll have an
unproductive day and he goes that's okay
I'll rationalize it that's okay you're
fine you've been busy it's okay and
they'll have another and another in
another and I'll keep trying to hide it
and I was like yep and that's when I
realized I was in it and so one of the
first things I did was I when I had we
had an all you know an all hands team as
we always do we had one of our company
uh All Hands meetings I said I'm I'm
going through it guys I said I'm really
struggling hard I said my sleep
pattern's off I'm not motivated I'm
struggling to ask for help I'm going
through this and I just need you to all
be a little patient with me I'm figuring
it out I'm sorting it out I'm asking for
help but I'm I'm not going to be very
good right now and I just need you as a
team I need you to be patient with me
that I did that to my team
um made it possible for them to do that
to me
if I had pretended that I was happy
throughout all of it I would have put
pressure on everybody who was struggling
to pretend that they were being happy
and the worst part about that as a
leader is then how can I help
if I don't know
and we make the mistake very often that
when somebody's High performing that
they're fine because some people the way
they manage stress is to double down at
work so their performance will actually
be through the roof and they're
struggling really hard so performance is
no indication of someone's stress and so
I think when um the ability to be
vulnerable is one of the greatest and
most difficult
Leadership Lessons any of us can learn
but it is so important to building trust
when people see us as human because it
allows them to be human too